In my opinion, score on the Laraway personality test does not have an everyday
meaning. In other words, you don't necessarily know what the scores on this
test mean without specialized training. By the way, I just made this test up.
It doesn't really exist. Notice the rest of these, number of correct items on
an exam, that has an everyday meaning. We all know what that means. Same with
the number of minutes to fix a flat tire. And the number of hours slept. So in
cases where we don't understand what the variable is telling us. A mean
difference may not be the most informative measures. And for that reason,
statisticians have developed other effect size measures, that we will now
discuss.